Hello, testing 130. Testing, testing. Is
it on? Yeah, it sounds fine now, yeah.
All right. Yeah, it is your deceptive
camera recording, screen recording
causing the problem. I'm only joking.
Yeah, yeah. See, I can think. So, what I
was trying to say is I'm happy to see
that you've got a normal question on and
you're not trying to provoke false
narratives today. You're just asking a
simple question. Let me Let me ask you
on something on that. Yeah. When you say
like a deceptive title or a provocative
What is What is like What would you be
referring to? What does that look like?
Well, you have them quite often on your
lives. So, it's just a case of this is a
simple question which is not applying
any bias. It's not saying whether you're
for Christianity or against Islam or
anything like that. It's simply asking a
question. When a question puts a preface
of a bias on what it's asking, that's
when it's, you know, a deceptive
question. So, that's
you say something like something like
Allah help the true Christians change my
mind? Something like that you'll say
runs into like the deceptive titles?
Well,
I don't want to discuss basically, you
know,
a non a mute point. It's not really
No, that's a good I I like to get
feedback. That's all. Yeah, all I'm
saying is
a lot of stuff you know the answers to
and you're just asking the question to
create a argument, debate or, you know,
get a rise out of people. Well, I I know
I know that the questions or titles that
I have, I You're right. I do have the
answers to them, but Muslims don't.
That's why I ask them. Yeah. So, the
Injil, you know what the Injil is, yeah?
It's the word that Jesus had that was
written down
by his apostles that were with him at
the time he was alive. Okay.
And it is the testament of Jesus. As you
know, in the Bible, it's called the red
letters, yeah? A red letter Bible is the
words that Jesus spoke from himself. You
do not have a Bible or Gospel with a
complete, you know, verse by word verse
of red letters. You've got accounts from
different apostles, some who are not,
you know, valid, some who are outright
liars, and some who were not even in the
time of Jesus, etc. Okay. So, the Gospel
is simply the word of Jesus that Jesus
actually spoke and that was written down
at the time.
So, you So, you would say that you would
say that the red letter Bible is the
Injil? No, no. I'm I'm saying the best
that you have is the red letters. That's
it. So, is So, I don't I That's what the
So, I'm still confused. So, basically,
how you like to Is it Is it the Injil or
not? What's the Injil? You do not have
the Injil. Did you hear
Okay. Okay, good. So, I don't have the
Injil. No, the the the How do you How do
you How do you know that I don't have
the Injil? Okay. As I said, if you had
the Injil, you'd have verse by verse of
what Jesus wrote and spoke. He didn't
write, but what he spoke and was written
down at the time.
How do you know that that's how the
Injil was formulated?
Because what Jesus spoke was the word of
God, yeah? Well, hold on. I'm just I'm
just a little confused. So, you said
that Jesus' apostles wrote the Injil,
right? The the verbal message that he
preached his apostles who were with him,
they wrote it down. That's what you
said, correct?
No, I said
the What I meant was that or, you know,
I'm not trying to allow you to make out
that Paul, Luke
I've only I've only just repeated what
you said.
Yeah, yeah. So, okay, I'll make myself
clear then. So, what I'm saying is the
the words that came out of Jesus' mouth
that were the words of God, revelation
given unto him with the Holy Spirit that
was with him, Who wrote it?
Who wrote it? Can you Let's do a basic
simple thing. Do you have the words of
Jesus that he first spoke just after he
was born?
Who says that he spoke words after he
was born? Well, the Quran testifies that
he spoke when he was a baby, when he was
still in the cradle. The Infancy Gospel
of Thomas. Yeah. So, when you try to
make the claim that your apostles have
written the word of Jesus down at the
time of him being alive, funny they
didn't they didn't record him speaking
in the cradle which would have been a
marvel for anyone to see.
Well, actually somebody did actually.
That you Somebody recorded Jesus
speaking from the cradle hundreds of
years before Muhammad did in the Quran.
It comes from a Gnostic fabricated
Gospel of Thomas. Okay. So,
again, you can then take this back to
all the other modern-day hippy versions
of saying that the epic of Gilgamesh or
the story of Horus, all these describe
the birth of Jesus and that the Bible is
a fabrication of based off Well, no,
they don't. Wait. Wait. They don't. They
don't, Riz. They don't. But, here's a
here's a here's a problem. When you have
a Gnostic proven forgery that has this
story of Jesus literally speaking from
the cradle, it's the only place that
it's that it's found. Nowhere else. It's
in a fabricated Gnostic Gospel written
hundreds of years after the disciple
Thomas actually lived, but they put his
name on it. The Infancy The Infancy
Gospel of Thomas. Right. Let's assume or
let's take your stance that that Gospel
or that Gnostic book was fabricated and
it's a lie.
it's not an assumption. It's literally
fact. It's Okay. Okay. Let's say that
that's a fact for from your perspective
and I agree for for the time being.
Okay. The the Quran is 100% truth. Not
one word of the Quran is false. Okay.
So, if the Quran says he speak spoke
from the cradle, yeah? That means that's
a categorically truthful statement by
the
Lord of the worlds which is Allah or the
creator of the heavens and the earth
that you believe in, yeah? Or the father
in heaven. He testifies that Jesus spoke
when he was in the cradle. So, would you
be saying that that fabricated Gospel is
an inspiration from Allah? What I would
say is that Gospel testifies to the
truth that may have been witnessed at
that time. So, a fabricated a fabricated
Gospel testifies to the truth of that
time that he got from who? Cuz Jesus
didn't write that nor say it. So, this
this forger
got revelation from Allah that Jesus
spoke from the cradle? No, they it would
be a witness at the time. Yeah, but it's
not a witness at the time. The Infancy
Gospel of Thomas is a 2nd and 3rd
century writing. Comes hundreds of years
after the time. Yeah, I know. So, you're
trying to say that the this came from a
Gnostic The idea of Jesus speaking from
the cradle came from the Gospel of
Thomas. I'm not saying that it did.
You're the one who made that assumption.
Yeah. You're the You're the one who's
making that assumption. Yeah, and you
and you granted it. Like not saying that
you believe it, but you granted it for
the sake of this argument. So, if you
grant like Okay, let's say that that's
true, but the Quran is true and the
Quran affirms that this actually took
place. So, okay. Now, I'm going with
that logic. So, if the Quran is actually
affirming that this actually took place
and it's true, how did the person who
forged this story know that? Was it
divine revelation from Allah? Cuz he
comes hundreds of years after the the
event. So, how did he know this? He
would have had to be present. But, how
if he came hundreds of years after?
Because he would have had the
information just as you've got the Bible
hundreds of years later. It would have
been Now, all the witnesses that were
there. The Bible doesn't come hundreds
of years later. The Bible is first is
dates back to the 1st century. Okay.
Okay, what what came behind before that?
It was the Old Testament, yes or no? Old
Testament.
that
I I
God love it. You've got to make this You
can't make out that the Bible is the
centerpiece, the only truth, yeah? You
know that before the Bible came, the Old
Testament.
That's not what I'm doing, Riz. You are.
You are. You're trying to make out that
the Bible The Bible was the first thing
that we had.
It really It's not me. You You put
yourself in a hole
I'm not putting myself in a hole. You
did. By saying that you grant that the
Infancy Gospel of Thomas is telling the
truth, now you have to answer for how
did the author of the Infancy Gospel of
Thomas, who lived hundreds of years
after the event, how did he know that
Jesus spoke from the cradle? How was he
able to write that down? Something that
he himself could not have possibly
witnessed. Okay. So, the assumption
Well, there's no assumption here. This
is what a basic You call yourself God
Logic, so apply some logic. At the time
of Jesus being alive, I'm about to I'm
about to trademark that joke and make
sure you guys pay me every time someone
says Oh, what? People have said that to
you before, haven't they? Every stream,
bro. Yeah, so So, that's good. It means
intelligent people converse with you
that you understand that they point out
what you're failing on. So, at the time
of Jesus being alive,
there would have been witnesses who saw
him speak from the grave. One of those
witnesses, guess who it was? One of the
most important people in his life, his
mother, yeah? And then many others would
have witnessed him speaking from the
grave. The the the Pharisees, the
Sadducees, everyone else who's in his
life, yeah? So, some of those would have
Whether they believed in Christ or not,
would have wrote the account of a
miracle child speaking from the grave
from the cradle, yeah?
Got it. So, you don't have to be a
believer. You don't You could be a
historian. You could be a philosopher.
You don't have to be a Christian at that
time. You would have wrote down that
this baby spoke from the grave which was
a miracle, yeah? All right. So, here's
my question to you with that then, too.
Okay? So, let's say that, you know, they
they just they just documented this true
event that took place and they, you
know, carried the tradition on this true
tradition and it kept, you know, getting
passed down, you know, from generation
to generation, this true historical
thing that happened, right? This
miraculous thing. So, by the time it
gets to Muhammad, can't we just say that
it's this was not a revelation, but it's
something that he heard and that was a
popular, well-known event that took
place, that it's not revelation from
God, but it's just something that
happened? That Muhammad heard happen?
No, absolutely not, because every verse
from the Quran was a revelation inspired
by God to Muhammad and his people.
How's that a How's that a revelation if
this is something that has been
circulated already? Because
you Again, apply logic here, yeah?
You're in an area
I'm trying to use logic.
Okay. So, I know you know the answers to
all of these things. So, I'm only saying
this for the benefit of the audience,
yeah? Which is that So, remember we're
talking, you know, 1,400 years ago
or whatever, they the means of travel
was camels, donkeys, walking, and going
from one peninsula to another peninsula
would take
Also ships. They had boats. They had
boats, but what I'm saying is a very
slow method of traversing from area to
area. Yeah? So, and the time of
Muhammad, peace be upon him, came was a
time of as you know, idolatry. He came
to destroy idolatry and bring the
worship of one God. What does that have
to do with anything we're talking about,
bro? What that has to do is that you're
assuming that Muhammad, peace be upon
him, collected all these stories about
the Bible and then made an amalgamation
of the Jewish Old Testament, the Bible,
and then a new religion, which is Islam,
and then combined them to bring three
different religions together and then
form one, which would be the leading
religion in the world today. That's a
whole assumption. Wait, wait. If if we
have
stuff in the Quran
that are already told and these
traditions already existed before the
Quran claim before the Quran came. These
are well-known stories that are you
know, making its tour its rounds from
nation to nation, generation to
generation. And Muhammad, being a, you
know, he worked with He was a trader
himself, so he would hear stories, he
would meet people, hear all kinds of
things and tales and fables. That sounds
pretty reasonable that he can take these
stories that he's hearing and put it
into his Quran.
Makes perfect sense to me. Okay. So,
again, these are things that people of
the time of Muhammad, peace be upon him,
being around would have also said to him
and have been documented within the
Quran. They say that he's a poet, you
know, Well, well, no, they they said
No, do you Do you want to know what they
said, Riz? What did they
said, "We heard this stuff already."
He's just telling us fables of old. Yes.
That's They're literally accusing him of
this. Yes, they can accuse him that and
it's a reminder. The word in the Quran
is
a reminder. It comes up a lot, which is
that they stories of old are repeated
for you because one, they've forgotten
the stories of old or, you know,
corrupted them or sold them for money
and then changed the words of God for
something else. So, those stories are
retold in the correct manner. Do you Do
you see Do you see the type of
the type of reach that you have to go to
defend Muhammad and his prophet?
Okay. All right, so let me let me
destroy your whole logic right now,
then, yeah? You claim that Muhammad,
peace be upon him, copied the Bible or
the Old Testament, yeah? I'm going to
ask you one question.
I didn't I didn't say that. Okay, okay.
Well, you're You're making that kind of
assertion, which is that that's where
he's got his stories from, that he heard
it from someone else, and that he's put
it in the Quran.
Yeah, I mean, that's that's that's
literally what the Quran and your Hadith
say. The Quran and the Hadith say
literally say that Muhammad was learning
from someone who was writing down stuff
for him. Your Hadith say there was a
Christian who used to scribe, used to be
a writer for Muhammad, converted to
Islam, used to scribe for him. And he
says that Muhammad only knows
what I told him. He doesn't know
anything else. He don't know nothing. He
needs idols.
So, God logic, this is what you do and
this is what's what I don't like about
you is you make categorically false
statements, yeah? There's an aspect of
There's an aspect of that which is true,
but then you put a complete whole
context to that which is false, yeah?
So, what What did I say that was false?
So, you made out the statement that uh
what Muhammad's knowledge was was only
from this Christian scribe that you
said. That's a false statement. I said
that that's what the Christian said.
The Christian made that statement, not
me.
Yeah, I know, but it's still something
you're trying to assert that By the way,
by the way, he he was a Muslim when he
said it and then left Islam because he
found out that Muhammad's not really a
prophet because he's just taking things
what He only knows what I tell him.
So, I can't He can't be a prophet. He's
not getting revelation. All right, so
let's get straight to the crux of it
where I just destroy this whole little
area of yours which you're trying to
build upon, which is that the Quran is
either a story made up and forged by
Muhammad, peace be upon him, or that,
you know, it's just copies of the Bible
and Torah just made anew. I never said
it's copies of the Torah made anew. I
never said that. All right, so so what
you're testifying is the Quran is its
revelation and it's the truth. Is that
what you're testifying?
I'm I'm testifying that the Quran is not
revelation. It is mixed up with fables,
stories of old with an Islamic twist to
it. Okay, so I'll ask you one question,
then. Can you tell me was Aaron
responsible for the making of the golden
calf?
Uh yeah, he had He had He had a dealing
with it. So, would you say he is going
to hell or he's a sinner or he's looked
down in the eyes of God? He repented. If
you read the Torah, he repented. Okay,
so no, again, this is a false story from
the Torah and the Bible. How do you know
that? Well, because because the Quran is
100% truth and it accounts for that
entire story, which you
not you personally, but the Christians
and the Jewish community have corrupted.
So, they assume that Aaron had a part to
play in the making of the the Honestly,
you you don't really have to even
continue. I know what you're doing.
You're You're all you're doing Listen.
All you're doing is you're proving
can you tell me what What does the Quran
say about If you're not going to let me
If you're not going to let me finish. We
don't have to. I'm sorry. We don't have
to waste time on that. That's what I
like I like to
Oh, so what you're saying is the point
that I was going to win you on, you
don't want to waste time on it. Okay.
Well, no, you're not my point because
all you're doing, bro, is you're proving
my point, actually. You're proving
What you're doing is using words like
the snake and trying to win points based
on words. I'm providing evidence. I
don't want to have to mute you. So, if
I'm going to have to start doing that,
I'm going to have to just mute you.
Okay. All right, good. So, what you're
doing, Riz, is you're proving my point.
You're showing me where Muhammad heard a
story from the Torah and then put an an
Islamic twist on the story. So, you're
not disproving what I said. You're
actually proving what I said. So, going
and showing where the Quran repeats the
story of the golden calf, but puts an
Islamic twist on it, shows that it's not
original to Muhammad. We have this story
in the Torah. He just changed it around
a bit. Okay, would you like me to give
you an example which is not in the Bible
and not in the Torah and that you can't
say it's used from the Bible, but
actually it's
it's provable today? What What Can you
Can you respond to what I what I did
what I said? No, no, what you said You
haven't really given We're using We're
using the examples that we have. The The
The first example that you brought,
Jesus speaking from the cradle. This
example, the the story of the golden
calf. All of these are traditions that
existed long before Muhammad. So, how is
it a revelation if it already existed?
If these traditions were already
popular? How is that a revelation of
Muhammad, being a trader who's listening
to Jews recite the Torah in Arabic,
who's close with Waraka, who's a
Christian writing the gospel for him,
who had Christian scribes for him, who
converted to Islam according to this
Hadith, one Christian? How How is this
revelation when he's learning these
things from people?
It's revelation because it's correcting
false
narrations that you have already. So,
meaning you believe that Jesus' name is
Jesus, yeah? Or you might call him
Yahweh. But what I'm saying is the name
you and modern day people know Jesus as
is Jesus. And you know that's
categorically false. There's no name
that was ever given of Jesus. So,
therefore, a revelation is something
that comes to correct previous and it's
not because the previous revelation was
false, it's because the previous people
sold the revelation for either money or
for, you know, worldly power. So, that's
what revelation is. You
I hear you.
Let's get back to Let's get back to the
Injil thing cuz we kind of
went away from that and I allowed it
cuz, you know, I'm I'm chill. I'm having
a good time. You're fun to talk to.
Yeah, I'm chill as well. I'm chill as
well. It's just that you're doing your
little magician trick.
Let's get back to what you said about
the Injil. So, you said that the Injil
is the message that Jesus brought, a
revelation from Allah through Jesus,
that his apostles wrote down for him.
That's what you said in the beginning.
Do you still hold to that? Faith, which
you don't have, I said.
No worries. But do you hold that the
Injil was written down by the apostles
of Jesus? Yes. Would you say that Mary
was an apostle as well?
No. No, why Why wouldn't you say Mary
was an apostle? One One second.
Anyway, God logic, I've got to put my
phone on charge. I'm more than happy to
discuss this with you another time, but
thank you for having me on and having
Please stay with the topics that are
not, you know, biased in any way. Just
simple questions.
I'm never biased. I just expose Islam.
That's all. No, you you don't expose it
because all you do is cast a light on
the fastest growing religion in the
world, which is the truth. Yeah, I cast
a light on it cuz it's full of darkness.
It needs light. No, no, no, you cast a
light on light. Light upon light. That's
all already in the Quran.
Darkness. I I want you to come back when
you can, Riz, so we can talk about this
Injil. Oh, we can talk about anytime.
Like I said, I've got to my phone, but
I'm not running or anything. It's again,
you you've kind of run away from the
topic quite a few times, but like I say
away I ran away from talking about the
Injil? No, you ran away from discussing
any point that would have
you know made it apparent that I was
telling the truth or I had evidence to
back up what I'm saying.
You really gave excuses and then now
you're saying that your phone is dying.
No, no, no. I'm on 26%. It's just a case
of I know that these debates can get
long and if I
Put it Put it on a charger. What's wrong
with that? Because in rooms where the
charger is, there's a lot of noise. So
hence why I'm already standing in the
hallway. Just to discuss this with you.
Okay. You know, I testify the truth. I
don't talk lies here. I'm telling you
straight up. But yeah, All right, I'll
see you next
But God logic, tell me why you're not
Muslim. That's what You need to become a
Muslim. Why aren't you Muslim? Because I
can't find where Jesus mentioned
Muhammad. That's in the Bible. You know
that as well.
hey, if you can show me that Song of
Solomon
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I I
promise you this. If you show me that, I
promise you I will become a Muslim right
there. Okay.
And you know that many Muslims have come
here and shown you the Song of Solomon
and many of the verses where Yeah, and
they and they've all been refuted. So
Yeah, that's it. You you replace the
truth
telling you what I need to become a
Muslim. I need to see where Jesus
mentions the coming of Muhammad, Jesus
himself, cuz the Quran says he does. So
if I can see that, I'll become a Muslim.
Okay, but let me ask you one more
question. If Jesus When Jesus comes back
your phone is dying, man. Yeah, it's on
a 25% now.
Okay, so you got time. Let's talk about
the Injil if you got time to talk.
but answer me this. If Jesus descends in
there
all these questions, then you have time
to answer about the Injil.
Yeah. So do you have time or not?
I've got time. It's just I didn't want
to get caught off midway, but go ahead.
Okay. All right, yeah. I've got time.
I've got time. I've got I'll I'll give
you a room and running commentary of my
you affirm So you affirm that the Injil
was written by the apostles of Jesus. Is
that correct? No, you you're not
listening You're You're me
earlier. You affirmed it and now you're
taking it back.
The Injil is the word of Jesus inspired
by God through the Holy Spirit that was
written
it? Anyone could have wrote it. A
non-believer could have wrote it.
As I told you, a historian could have
wrote it. Anyone could have wrote it
down.
wrote the Injil? No.
So who wrote it?
What I'm saying is believers would have
wrote the Injil and it would have been
the people that Jesus was closest with
that he would have given Like Like his
mother. His mother being one of them. So
his his mother wrote the Injil?
I'm saying many people with Jesus would
have wrote an account of the Injil, but
the Injil was
Who wrote the Injil, though? Yeah. Okay.
So again, this is a common problem with
you, God logic, and many Christians. You
fail to understand You You like to use
the word in your own book, which was the
word. You confuse what the word is. You
think that word means that Jesus or God
was there in the beginning. The word is
revelation, yeah? The revelation is not
something that is written down. The
revelation is something that is spoken,
yeah? So what was spoken?
Was the Injil
The Injil is what was spoken, yeah? Was
the Injil
written down by people.
Just like the Quran is written down
today, but Quran is a spoken revelation,
so was the Injil.
I got you. So the Injil is a spoken
revelation in eventually written down.
No, not eventually. You know when a baby
speaks from the cradle, it's written
down straight away, yeah?
Okay.
Okay, so who wrote the Injil?
Like I said, there would have been many
people in Jesus' life
And then if there would have been many
people, who did it?
Again, what That would be pure
speculation cuz I know that you don't
have the Injil and we don't have the
Injil, so therefore we can't locate it.
Let me ask you this. If I were to say
that you don't have the Quran today, yet
I never read the Quran, I never seen the
Quran, but I come to you and I say you
don't have it. What you have is not the
Quran. What would you say to me? I'd say
that we can go all the way back to the
first revelation, yeah? Okay. So you
didn't go all the way back to the first
revelation. Nice. Yeah, because one way
in the You You know the answer to Let me
answer God logic. You've got to let me
answer, God logic. If you don't let me
answer it.
you can
No, no, no. I'm not going to get So you
would say you can go back to the and I
said that that's not it. I said that
that's not it. What you have is just not
it. What would you say? The answer lies
within the information I was going to
give you that you didn't let me answer,
which is we've got scripture in the
original language and we have witnesses
who
that's not it.
You You don't have an Aramaic Bible,
complete Aramaic Bible.
if I said that what you're telling me is
original Arabic Quran and witnesses of
the Quran and I still tell you that's
not it, though. That's not the original.
What would you say to me? Even though
I've never seen it, I never read the
Quran, I never seen the Quran, but I
come and I tell you that you what you
and the evidence you have is not the
Quran.
What would you say?
I'd say we agree to disagree. That's one
good because the Quran does has a strict
no compulsion in religion, meaning you
can't force religion on anyone.
asking about religion. I'm asking about
the I'm talking about the fact of your
Quran. I'm saying you don't have it,
although I never Let me ask you this,
then. Let me just switch the question
around.
But you do quite a lot. Go ahead.
If I say If I were to say and hold the
position, you don't have the Quran. I
never seen the Quran, though. I've never
read the Quran. I've never witnessed the
Quran. But I say what you have, you
don't have it. Is that a smart and good
position to hold? Only if you have
verifiable information to prove the fact
of the information
I just said I never seen a Quran. I
never read a Quran.
So how can I have verifiable facts and
prove that what you have is not the
Quran? If I've never seen, touched,
heard of, witnessed a Quran in my life.
How can I tell you that there's no
Quran? That you What you have is not it.
You can't. Exactly. So I would have I
would have a position that is baseless
and has no evidence, correct? That's
right. Okay. So now I'm going to ask do
it to you now. Now you was able to
understand that when the roles were
flipped. Now let's flip roles. Logic, I
understand everything you're saying.
You're trying to play me now. Come on.
Have you ever seen the Injil? No. Have
you ever read the Injil? No. Have you
ever witnessed the Injil? No. So how do
you know that I don't have the Injil?
How can you tell me if you never seen
it, never witnessed it, never read it,
never touched it? How can you tell me
that I don't have the Injil when you
have no evidence of the contrary? Oh, we
have evidence and that's the Holy Quran,
which accounts for many No, no. You can
laugh. You can laugh, but let me give
you the example, okay? The
Surat al-Ma'idah, the table, yeah? Can
you tell me about the table? The only
thing you know about the Last Supper is
Leonardo da Vinci, yeah? You don't know
the real story about the Last Supper,
yeah? So therefore, why does the Quran
give more information about the Last
Supper than the your Bible does and Leo
don't
Leonardo da Vinci? Tell Really? Who was
Who was at the Last Supper? The Quran
gives more information about the Last
Supper than your Bible or
Leonardo da Vinci.
Good. Tell me. From the Quran, who was
at the Last Supper? The apostles of
Jesus.
Who are they? You wouldn't know who they
are, neither would I.
at the the
It's It's amazing to me because the
Injil that I have actually gives the
names who were there at the Last Supper.
Does your Quran tell you who exactly was
there? The The emphasis being on what
happened at the Last Supper. One second.
I thought I was on break today. I'm
sorry.
I thought I was on break today, but You
thought you was on a break from lying.
You're never on a break from lying. You
lie every day, God logic. I thought I
was on break today, but you you you made
me bring it out. You're making me bring
it out. But what's this? Chess logic.
Chess logic. And and and I'm at You're
You're sizzling. You're simmering and I
got to flip you over another side. Go
on. Go on. Go on.
there at the Last Supper according to
your Quran? Who was there? I need The
apostles. You said You said that your
Quran gives me names or gives me more
details than what I have. So give me the
details. Who was there? Okay, if you
want to fly a plane, do you need the
instructions on how to fly the planes or
do you need the names of the passengers?
Hold on a second. Was it I or was it you
who said that I don't know anything
about the new about the Last Supper, but
your Quran tells me what happens at So
So So you So you know a lot of fake
names of people who weren't really
there.
How about this?
Can you show me where your Quran calls
it the Last Supper? The chapter called
Surat al-Ma'idah, Yeah, go to Go to
Surat al-Ma'idah and show me where it
calls it the Last Supper. It doesn't
call it the Last Supper. Then where are
you getting this phrase from? This Last
Supper. Where are you getting this
phrase?
Okay. So God logic, this is where you go
into stupidity when you understand
mode. This is why I go into chef mode.
No, no, no, no. You're not in chef mode.
You're in stupidity mode. Where are you
Where are you getting this from? This
phrase, this title of this event called
the Last Supper. Where do you get this
from? I I get it from your modern-day
interpretation of something that never
happened, yeah? So you get it from the
Christians? From our sources? Okay, so
instead of calling All right, so I'll
call Jesus Isa from now on and from for
all your listeners who don't even know
what the meaning of Isa is, which is the
true name of Jesus, yeah? And you're
you're still going to call him Jaze,
which is not even in the Hebrew or the
Aramaic Bible or the Okay. Now Now So So
So not only do you steal the title of
the event from Christians that you say
you have information about and we don't,
yet you're stealing the title of the
whole event from us. I'm not stealing
anything from you. If I said Here's
number two. Here's number two.
You don't even know who was there.
Who was there? You still haven't told
me. Who was at the Last Supper? I told
you the apostles, his followers. Who
Wait. Wait. First of all, show me in the
Quran where it says where it says the
apostles were there. Why do you Where do
you get this title of apostle from?
The point is the followers of Jesus who
believed in Jesus were with him. That's
Where do you get this title, this idea
that Jesus had what is called apostles?
Is that in your Quran? So, what you're
trying to do is argue over the
dictionary terms of the English
So, can you speak to me in Aramaic from
now on, constantly?
I thought I was on break, yeah. No, no,
you you you are on break cuz you don't
understand that you don't speak Aramaic.
You don't speak Aramaic at all. So, I
speak Arabic. You don't speak
So, go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go
No, no, if you speak Aramaic, I'll
concede the point that you destroyed me.
If you speak Aramaic, speak Aramaic.
Speak Aramaic. I wasn't going to bring
this out. Speak Aramaic.
You Look what you did, mate.
Look Look what you did. Listen to me,
dude. Logic, you got destroyed by You
got destroyed by many other Muslims
before me. I'm just trying to chill. I'm
just here to talk to you. I'm trying to
eat my meal. I'm trying to meal prep.
MAN, YOU GOT me cooking, man.
YOU GOT ME YOU GOT ME COOKING. OH, MAN.
I was trying to chill today. Look what
you made me do, man. Become Muslim.
The Quran is 100% true. I guarantee it.
Come on, man. So,
so so so so so here it is here. Here it
is. Here it is. Here it is. You You
stole the title of the event last
summer.
No, no, no, I used the title to relate
it to something that you'd be able to
understand. He He didn't even say it. He
didn't say it. Number two, you don't
know who was there. And again, where are
you getting this idea that Jesus had
that apostles were there? Where does it
Where does your Quran say that apostles
were there? His followers were there.
You called You called them apostles. You
called them apostles. We call them
followers. Wait, who calls them
apostles? You do. Wait, why are you
stealing our titles and what we give
them, what the Bible says about them?
Why are you stealing from the Bible when
you claim that you have more information
about them from without the Bible? Why
are you stealing from us? I'm not
stealing from you. I'm just speaking
English. Were they apostles or not? Had
we been speaking Aramaic or Arabic this
entire time
or not? Logic, no, logic logic, you're
speaking the English language. You're
You're speaking the language you
understand what's going on. No, no, I do
understand. I overstand. Okay, can you
tell me where did the English language
come from?
Answer, where did the English language
to help you.
No, no, you're not helping me. You're
helping yourself sound from sounding
stupid. I'm trying to keep you from
sounding stupid. The word apostle is not
the same word as follower. Those are two
different words.
Even the Even the term disciple the term
disciple, the term follower, and the
term apostle are three different words.
They're not the same thing, okay? Not
every disciple is an apostle, all right?
Not every follower is an apostle. Not
every follower is a disciple. These are
three different words. So, why are you
calling the disciples of Jesus or the
I'm sorry. Why are you calling the
followers of Jesus as you renegade on
this? Why are you calling them apostles?
Why? Where are you getting this from?
Does your Quran call them apostles?
That's what I want to know. Brother, I'm
mute. Okay, the reason I call them many
different terms in English, which is the
language that you speak and not Aramaic,
which is the language that Jesus spoke,
yeah.
The reason I use these English terms is
because you have so many different
versions of the Bible. I don't know what
word that you would choose to call your
disciples, apostles, or followers. Come
on. You just said that you get it from
that you're you know, that Jesus spoke
Aramaic. And that was his original
language. Where do you get that from?
Can you show me in the Quran where it
says Jesus spoke Aramaic? It's from See,
not everything needs to be from the
Quran. This is from history. Jesus was
from the Aramaeans.
me. You told me. You don't listen to the
answer and then you just carry on. This
is the reason we're here. We're You're
cooking yourself into sickness. Because
you're just embarrassing yourself. It's
really bad. We're here because you said,
not me,
not anybody in the comments, you made
the erroneous claim that you from the
Quran have more information and details
about Jesus, about the Last Supper. You
said the Quran gives you more details
than what I have. I have nothing. Okay?
I have nothing. You can't tell me who
the disciples are. You can't tell me
where you get this title apostle from.
You said that they were apostles. You
can't even tell me where in the The
Quran doesn't tell you that it was
called the Last Supper. You get that
from Christians. You get that from
Christians. Yes, I told you the
chapter's called the Hold on one second.
I wasn't done either.
I never used You're assuming that Jesus
spoke Aramaic. From where? He was from
the Aramaeans, yeah. The Aramaeans? The
The who?
The Aramaeans. The Aramaeans. Yes. Say
it again. He's from where? Oh, you can
smile. You don't even speak Aramaic and
you're trying to laugh.
Laugh laugh laugh, laugh, people. Become
Muslim. That's the only point This guy
is lying to you, deceiving you. He's
taking the side of Shaytan,
Iblis.
What did I do to deserve such a good day
today? Wow. The Aramaeans? Jesus is from
the tribe of Aram, y'all.
The Aramaeans. They used to They used to
you know, go hunting during the
month of Ramadan, too.
The Aramaeans. Can you show me in the
Quran where it says Jesus was from the
Aramaeans? Can you show me in in the
dictionary what what an Aramaean is?
Okay. So, a language doesn't determine
which locations or which
cast or tribe someone comes from, yeah?
Jesus comes from the house of David,
yeah? Not from the the tribe of
Aramaeans, yeah? Where does your Where
does your Quran say that Jesus comes
from the house of David? See, so instead
of answering the information and
questions I'm asking you, you just
constantly skip to different questions.
I destroyed you. I cooked you on Aaron.
Where does your Quran say
Jesus from is from the house of David?
Show me that. Show me. Okay, answer this
question then in order for your stupid
logic to be able to follow. Which
No, no, which tribe did Jesus come to
die? Whoa.
Yes. Okay, I'm I'm going to give you the
answer, but I need to make sure your
LOGIC IS WORKING.
NO, NO, I'M
I'M STILL CALM. It's just that I'm
trying to
You're doing your regular cartoon show.
Remember, guys, this is doing cartoon
showing. He's lying to you. I'm here to
testify the truth.
My brother.
Just show me where your Quran says
Jesus is from the house of David. Show
me that. In Surah Saba, give thanks, oh
house of David. Few of my bondmen are
thankful.
Yeah? That's the word verse. I've given
it to you right now. Okay, you you can
laugh, but you have not You can't make
this guy You can't the questions I've
given.
You can't make this up. Look. That's the
verse that says Jesus is from the house
of David. I've got to say, the weakest
link. Goodbye. Bye.
Bye-bye.